i always tell people anticipation is
power if you ever play a video game
against a child it's pretty disastrous
right maybe not for you for me it's not
the kid who's faster and smarter if they
played this game before eight million
times so they know the first shots here
the second shot third shot there and
you're like reacting when you're
reacting to things you fail my mentors
have been people over the year different
people my earliest mentor was a man
named jim rohn he was a personal
development speaker just touched my life
then i was involved in neuro-linguistic
programming nlp when i was 21 22 23
years old and became partners with a man
named john grinder brilliant man
co-founder of that but in my last couple
decades it's been people like peter
guber who's owns the la dodgers and owns
the golden state warriors nba team and
52 academy award nominations so he's a
mentor for me a paul tutor jones i coach
but also i'm coached by him because we
get to pitch and catch and then i've got
some people in my life that you know
steve wynn is a dear friend of mine and
these guys are all 18 years my senior so
they know the road ahead and i'm able to
learn from them in advance and kind of
anticipate things and that to me is
incredibly valuable yeah the fastest way
to accomplish anything is to model
someone who has already had the same
success that you are after you can go
around trying to figure out everything
by yourself trying to come up with every
new idea yourself and you will slowly
slowly make progress towards your ideas
but until you recognize that success
leaves clues that whatever the thing is
that you're trying to accomplish has
already been solved by thousands and
thousands of thousands of people that
all you need to do is model their
success until you realize that you're
going to constantly stay struggling
making slow progress knowing that you're
capable of more so i first learned the
power of violent success with my first
business where i was struggling i was i
was 19 20
not making any money 300 bucks a month
low confidence filled with self-doubt
not getting results you know i turned
down high paying jobs to do this thing
and own 30 of a company that seemed to
be going nowhere and i told my partner
that i quit and the thing that saved me
when i hit my lowest point was i am not
the first person to try to solve this
problem before maybe my specific
scenario yes biotech software you know
from toronto who's done that before
nobody but a software company getting to
a million dollars somebody's done that
before
how about i just look at their success
and try to emulate it and so the only
person i could think of off the top of
my head was bill gates so i looked at
bill gates and how he got started and it
was through partnerships and i applied
that lesson to my business and in a
short amount of time had my first deal
for 13 and a half thousand dollars i
felt like a rich man you know i felt
like holy cow
to go from 300 bucks a month and saying
i quit to now having a deal in place for
13 and a half k and more important the
strategy that i could use again and
again again was was life changing for me
all because i modeled success and that
was again when i was 19 20 so now what
have i done for the past 20 years is
just model success what is my youtube
channel about what is this video about a
lot of the success why i have these
people behind me it's not for you it's
for me i want to model success they're
constantly pulling me up to a greater
spot whatever problem you have
has been solved not exactly the specific
minutia but by modeling bill gates it
took me 80 percent of the way
you still have to figure out that final
20 percent but most people are trying to
figure out the whole hundred that's the
problem
i was struggling when i was trying to
figure out the whole hundred all by
myself i just come up coming up with new
ideas new ways new innovation but
nothing worked
[Music]
all you have to do is figure out that
last 20
and so look to your heroes look to
potential mentors whether you know them
in person or not they've done it before
they can teach you success leaves clues
you don't have to go through this alone
and you can ramp up your success really
quickly now how do you get a mentor
there's three different kinds i want to
break them down and teach you how to get
them let's go the first mentors are
in-person mentors these are people who
you meet for coffee people who you can
hang out with people you can sit you
know face to face with and ask them
questions they may not have had as big a
success right as much as you know i love
kanye west i haven't met him yet howard
chose i haven't met him yet
these two i'm never going to meet steve
jobs april jeanine i'm not but i haven't
met those two yet and even if i do or
when i do
you know i'm not hanging with kanye
every day over coffee asking him some
questions so there's people who have
some success but they may not be the top
of the top that's okay they're further
ahead than you are
and so you look at people who are local
look the people who you can make time to
connect with and ask them questions show
your hunger show your drive mentors love
giving back and helping out but they
hate wasting their time and they and
they feel like it's a waste of time
often because mentees suck most mentees
suck most mts don't do the work most
mentees don't do the work because it's
hard
and so you need to show to the mentor
that you will do the work that you will
follow through that you will you will do
it and then they'll feel great because
they'll see a younger version of
themselves in you that's what you want i
had a guy named carlos who wanted to do
an interview with me in toronto and he
was from new york i said okay you know
what if you get here from new york on
this day i'll do the interview with you
and so he took a bus overnight to get
here so it's a nine-hour bus to do the
interview with me and then he asked
afterwards i still have a couple hours
before i have to go back home and catch
my overnight bus again
right overnight bus
for half an hour in toronto and then
overnight bus right that was his point
can i hang out with you can i can i just
see what you're doing can i ask you more
questions and i i said you know what
yeah
and anybody else typically would have
said no to it and move on with my day
but i said yes and i brought him back to
my place and we filmed some more content
i asked answered some more questions
from him because he showed that he was
willing to work and this is a guy who's
going to win he doesn't let the fact
that somebody's in toronto and he's in
new york stop him even though he doesn't
have a car even though he couldn't
afford the flight right buys a bus
ticket overnight there and back even
though you know he's got a wife at home
and he's got responsibilities and a
full-time job and all of it he made it
work and so i want to help him
i want to help him i gave him extra time
that day i'm talking about him now here
you know on this video carlos shout out
i love you man you're going to crush it
that's the process so you can reach out
to people who have done what you want to
do and then share your story and show
your willingness to work show your
willingness to take their advice and
apply it you'll get far more yeses step
number two are what i call aspirational
mentors these are actually my favorite
these are people who i love learning
from that i may never meet or can't meet
right these two
i can't meet i'm never going to meet
steve jobs ap giannini is the founder of
bank of america he's my favorite
entrepreneur of all time i'm never going
to meet him either they're they passed
i've still learned a lot from kanye and
howard even though i haven't met them
yet you can learn from people you can
dissect their success and learn from
them even if you never meet them so if
you're saying well i'm in the middle of
nowhere and i can't get somewhere i
don't know anybody in my family i have
no connection zero how do i get started
don't let that defeat you
you could learn from aspirational
mentors that's what this channel is all
about find the people two types one who
are in your industry who've done it i
learned from bill gates because he was
in software and i was in software so
look at the people who've done it
anybody who's big even though i was in
biotech software and bill gates was in
productivity software that's 80 of the
rules are the same right how he did it i
can apply 80 to my success then you only
have to figure out that final 20
so look at people in your industry and
then look at people who you just love
look at people you look up to and
respect i love ep giannini who is the
founder of bank of america
because he was the believe banker even
though i'm not in banking
i love steve jobs even though i'm not
making tech gear i love howard schultz
even though i'm not you know creating
coffee right well i almost spilled it
i love kanji even though i'm not rapping
i can learn from all these people and so
can you if you love somebody for some
reason you can still learn from their
success because success leaves clues and
so you should definitely ramp up the
aspirational mentors that are filling
your head and the third kind of mentors
are a hybrid that i would call online
mentors and these are people who could
be aspirational mentors and you may
never meet them and you may never be
able to afford to hire you know
one-on-one with them but they're going
live online they're creating content if
they're just creating content and
they're just you know posting videos on
youtube or posting videos on instagram i
would call that an aspirational mentor
if tony robbins creates a video for
youtube you're learning from him it's
amazing right it's great i love it but
tony robbins may go live on instagram
lewis howes may go live on instagram
ivan carmichael goes live on instagram
multiple times per week every week you
can come in and ask questions
and so for all these people who you look
up to and respect
go to instagram turn on notifications go
to youtube look for when they go live
and when they're there be the first i
can't tell you how many times i go live
on instagram and people are afraid or
shy to ask questions at the beginning i
love bringing people in live where we're
both in their picture in picture
but at the beginning people are always
afraid they're afraid to ask the first
question they're afraid to put up their
hand and
and potentially be picked to come in
live
but after we get started after the first
few questions come in then it's a flood
of questions and then i can't answer all
of them
so take your shot follow your mentors
online you don't even need to be active
on instagram to follow people on
instagram and when they go live and you
have one burning question for tony
robbins for lewis howes for evan
carmichael get in there first raise your
hand and say me here's my question and
hopefully you get the advice that you
need and then your next job is do the
work whenever a mentor gives you advice
and says here's what you need to do go
and do it don't come back with a
different question 10 minutes later or a
week later go back and do the work and
do the work and do the work show that
you respect them and you're willing to
put the work in
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
you gotta everyday feed and strengthen
your body
and you gotta do something even in the
middle of covet if it's still there even
if it lockdown because if you don't take
of your body it affects your mind
doesn't it
i mean think about this what is it that
screws up everybody's life
fear is the number one thing it's keeps
people from doing what's necessary and
anger and rage well it can mobilize us
if it becomes part of your life on a
regular basis it destroys it so how do
you balance that out well
fear anger they're both physical aren't
they
think about what do you feel like if
you're really ever been so afraid that
your throat got really dry or you feel
this feeling in your gut
right that's physical
courage is also physical again courage
does not mean you're not afraid
courage means you're afraid but you do
it anyway right it's a way of being in
your body so one of the things that i
started doing early on is understanding
and those of you who spent four days
with me you know day and night because
we did it it's in your body still how to
change the way you feel instantly by a
radical change in your body and so i
really want to recommend you do
something at least five days a week
first thing when you wake up in the
morning i don't it doesn't have to be an
hour workout even 30 minutes it can be
something as little as 5 or 10 minutes
there is not a day when i wake up i've
shared with some of you this already
first thing i do i go outside and i'm
lucky enough to be at one of my homes
anyway i have homes in different parts
of the world because i've traveled the
world and done this i'm very fortunate
but i have a cold punch i've installed
in everyone 56 degrees and my home in
sun valley i know i don't have a cold
punch i don't need it i walk through the
snow in the winter in the summer i walk
through the grass and i get in the river
and then
literally the river is usually about 39
to 42 degrees to give you an idea
every cell in your body is moved the
blood rushes through everything right
and i do it for two reasons there's
never a day i look forward to doing it i
don't go oh i can't wait to go in there
i do it number one because it transforms
your body the blood flow the lymph flow
is unbelievable from a health
perspective you just go in for a minute
pop out it's like a different world
right i don't care what it is or you
could take a freezing shower would be
the minimum way you could do this you
couldn't do this but it's about changing
your body so radically and it's also
about
developing a simple daily discipline
it's like i don't negotiate with myself
i tell my brain i don't go oh wait i'm
not ready or let me let me count to 10
or maybe i'll do it tomorrow
that pattern of thinking is what
destroys most people's lives and their
dreams you can settle for a life like
most people have or you can create your
dreams but to do it you need to be able
to push yourself so you need to train
yourself in little ways or it could be
just going and lifting weights and
you're going to do like 10 minutes of
pushing yourself or a sprint or really
fast walk anything because when you get
your blood pushing when you push beyond
what's comfortable
it develops this determination inside
you this sense of will
that you will then use everywhere else i
always say if you discipline yourself in
one area of your life you're going to be
able to do it even more in other areas
you get momentum momentum is everything
so
if you train your mind great but you got
to train your body as well in some way
and i don't care again if it's five or
ten minutes when you really push
yourself or a full-blown workout it's
got to get there because when you do
that regularly you're going to find
yourself having a better mind the mind
and body can't be separated they're
completely connected you work on both of
them you're going to have a different
world and you're not going to be shut
down and when other people like oh it
can't be done just move i'll handle it
it's a different way of being isn't it
lifestyle's not about money
it's about two things
creativity and caring
it doesn't take money it just takes a
little creativity to think about those
you love and
think what would light them up it will
light you up more than anything else i
promise you
to surprise them to do beautiful special
things
little things
it makes people feel
important needed loved appreciated
what better way to invest
than invest in your relationships with
those you love
and you can't give joy to everybody else
that you love without giving joy to
yourself
and then there's another kind
the other kind is where you invest in
those you don't even know
not for stars on your chart
because you know it's right
it can be done with such a small amount
of money it's not money it's creativity
and caring
maybe it's animals that are abused maybe
it's
old folks that people don't pay
attention to anymore
maybe it's
providing one surgery for someone who
has lost sight and can see again
provide water for
a family great ideas are never going to
interrupt you they have to be pursued
and you if you don't pursue them you're
going to get what everybody else has
which is all this fear all this
uncertainty all this stuff won't work
because everybody's focused on what
won't work what can't happen why because
they're afraid they're afraid to fail
they're afraid to try and feel like
they're not enough so you've got to
stand guard that mind by feeding your
mind
you know jim rohn used to say to me
success leaves clues
if you want thing to get better you got
to get better if you want things to
change you got to change but you got to
do it deliberately and consciously and
he used to say to me constantly said
tony you've got to constantly find a way
to feed that mind something that's got
strategy in it philosophy something
that's going to improve the quality of
your life
and if you really learn it
you can help the people you love with
the things you learn
and so i got hooked and so i decided i'm
going to read a book a day i took a
speed reading course and i didn't read a
book a day but i read 700 books over the
period of seven years all in the area of
philosophy physiology emotion the things
to me that mattered most and what i
really try to do is each day try to use
something i learn not just read not just
let my
learning lead to knowledge you know jim
used to say if you let your learning
lead to knowledge you become a fool
if you let you learn to lead to action
that's when your life changes so i
started being aware of who was saying
what what i was taking in you know jim
used to say you know success leaves
clues if someone's successful they're
not lucky they're doing something
different than you figure out what
they're doing different he said the
first thing is find out what they're
reading
he said because he said i remember he
said me something funny he said find out
what poor people read and don't read it
and we said poor he didn't just mean
financially poor he meant people that
were unhappy people that were had no
sense of meaning in their life people
that were financially strapped because
they weren't managing to add value to
other people people that found
themselves not taking your relationships
their body poor isn't just money wealth
isn't just money it's emotional
spiritual everything he said so find out
what successful people do what wealthy
people read what happy people and read
that the difference between making it or
not is psychology and skill you need
both and honestly skill is the smaller
of the two i'm gonna give you a ton of
strategies this week i'm gonna do
psychology first and you're gonna see
why as this day goes by because you're
gonna discover when people stand up and
we figure out what's the chokehold on
their business 80 percent of the time
it's going to be their psychology
the choke hold on the growth of your
business is the psychology and skills of
the leader
period
that's it
and if we change those two things skills
two marketing skills financial
intelligence recruiting training all
those things between those two don't get
me wrong we got to do the skills also
but i could give you every skill how
many of you learned before that was
invaluable from some source a mentor a
coach an event a university i don't know
what
and you were excited about it and then
you never actually follow through who's
done this before say i
listen knowledge is not power
execution trumps knowledge every day of
the week
my goals make you execute i can't make
you but i can get you when you tap into
that part of yourself and that shift is
the most important shift of these few
days most of us in life we we work so
hard for things we think life's going to
be a certain way but as you're going to
discover life is never a straight line
you know we're taught that we think line
is just i'm going to go from here to
there but if you look in nature you
never see a straight line in real nature
if it's a straight line a human built it
and so it's a process of evolving of
growing dropping back growing dropping
back and and challenges are what really
grow us you know your life is a great
story you know every person's life is a
story the question is some people's
story is a warning some people's story
is an example right now you're an
example that's growing and expanding and
you have a chance to have this be the
most incredible life but it won't be a
life without challenge and the
challenges we're facing right now give
you an opportunity to grow like very few
generations you know i'm sure you've
heard of the great generation the world
war ii generation
if you watch a great movie if you read a
great book you know the size and the
power of the hero how much you become as
a hero is defined by how tough an
obstacle you face how difficult is the
villain the opponent and so sometimes
when i've been through the toughest
times in my life one of the questions
i've had to ask myself or note to myself
is ah i finally have a really worthy
opponent this is scaring the hell out of
me or this is challenging me this is
making me crazy but i also know of my
god and my soul that if i can push this
just like you've done in these years
you've pushed through tough times i'm
sure many of them but as you push
through those you become more as you
become more something magical happens
you don't just grow you expand in your
spirit and your soul and your capacity
and your skill and all of a sudden fear
becomes less and less a part of you it's
about growing and giving i know that's
overly simplistic but that's what i want
for her it's like you know it's about
laughing loving growing giving
you know and giving passionately and
generously and graciously it doesn't i
don't mean just money i mean of your
presence
you know it's very easy to say hello and
not be there it's very easy to say i
love you and you know it's just a habit
you know about
you know depending on which studies you
read about 47 to 52 of things we do are
just habit the cool thing about habit is
it allows you other things like you know
trying to drive a stick shift car in the
beginning is way it's overwhelming now
it's one thing i can do 20 other things
right
but the problem with it is
technology has made us become more and
more habitual
and less and less connected
and so from my daughter i wanted her to
experience love that's what life is to
me and when you are loving you have to
grow to keep loving and you when you're
growing and you're loving you're going
to give and to me if that's all she does
if she learns that life is not
what you're here to get
it's what you're gonna give that you're
being called to find what you're called
for and i don't know what to be called
for she you know may she might sing she
might draw art she might just be a mom
it's not just one of the most important
things in life she might i don't know
what she'll do and i have no
frame of reference about how she's going
to do it i have only one frame of
reference she's going to be a person
that's earned it and she's going to be a
person who's proud of herself because
the urn part to me
is where the pride comes it's like i
have this amazing life you could take
away all the toys and things that i have
you couldn't change who i've become as a
man yeah and and also because i never
had those things and i earned those
things there's there's the stories and
the examples and you know what it's like
right to conquer all the challenges to
get there i want my daughter to have all
those experiences but to me life is love
and life is growing and giving it's
really that's what the whole game is
about as far as i'm concerned all of us
we could take our work
and think of work as being like a gift i
personally believe
that one of the greatest gifts outside
my love that i can give another human
being is my labor but there's three
gifts of labor you might have within
your nature meaning
you can master anything but under stress
people tend to go back to their true
nature
and there are three gifts of labor that
you can give
one of those gifts we might call the
gift of being an artist
or a talent or another word for it be a
truly skilled producer
some people the reason you know this is
your gift is what you love to do
is to create a product or service and
deliver it to people and you're enamored
by that
the woman over here who is doing the
work if you recall you know in hospice
she would be a perfect example of an
artist she's not in it she wants to make
money don't get me wrong but she would
never trade the money for the impact
so when someone is in it as an artist
and by the way most businesses are
started by artists
there's somebody who was an amazing
negotiator an amazing fashion designer
amazing code writer and they said i work
for this company and they don't do a
good job for customers and i can do a
better job i don't work for them and
they start their own company
thinking that the company is all driven
just by the sales or the negotiation or
the code or the fashion but a company is
much more complex than that especially
as it grows
so an artist is in it for the impact
and yes they want to make money don't
get me wrong but it's not the first
thing and they won't trade it when i
talk to artists about selling their
business they look at me like i'm trying
to sell their child
the second gift you might have
is the gift of being a manager leader
a manager leader is someone who lives to
manage people and processes they love to
figure out how to maximize the business
by changing the gears creating a new
process working with people and those
people love it now they are not artists
in that their talent or skill they're
not there delivering it directly to the
client they want to work on the people
that directly got they want to work on
the system that makes this business work
and so they think it differently they're
inspired by different things they make
different decisions
is one better or worse than the other
yes or no
no they're just different and by the way
you might say i have both those skills i
bet you do but they're not equal
because they're different types of
skills so you might have them both
but there's one that is your true nature
that when things are going well you're
gonna go back to it when things are
really up you're going to go back to it
under stress and under excitement we
return to our nature by the way a great
company can't be great without great
artists talent who really deliver
extraordinary products or services a
company cannot maintain greatness and
grow unless they have some great manager
leaders who can run with the process and
the people they're both critical
components the third
choice of service the true gift you can
give is that of an entrepreneur
and while most of you in this room would
call yourself an entrepreneur and you
would be entrepreneurial
by this definition it's a little
different most people think of an
entrepreneur as anybody starts multiple
businesses no that's not true
some artists are multiple businesses
because they want to get all kinds of
things for all kinds of people some
managers want to do multiple businesses
so they feel like they have multiple
systems but entrepreneurs in it for one
thing
the juice of risk
they want to make money
and by the way an entrepreneur will they
sell this business yes or no for the
right price they'll sell anything and
their mindset is get sell it i'll start
another one sell it i'll buy another one
they are not attached they might enjoy
the product service they might be proud
of their product or service but they're
in it for the risk and they're the kind
of person that when they lose massively
they jump up dust themselves off and
want to do it again ultimately i really
believe
that the
probably the most i don't know the most
sacred thing in our lives that we can
give another human being besides our
love is our labor
you think about your labor is your
energy it's your time it's your emotion
it's your intellect it's your spirit to
some extent and if you can find a way
where
what you do for a living activates that
sense of what you're made for then work
is not work whether you be in fiji or
whether you be in a an environment that
might be seen less exciting and
promising in the moment trust me i've
worked in plenty of those too but with
the same level of excitement and passion
because i found what
turns me on that makes me feel alive
makes me feel like i'm doing something
that's worthwhile and on labor day i
think a lot of people it's just a
holiday to get away and take time off of
labor uh and my hope is to trigger you
to think about how could you turn your
labor into your love
i think it was uh mark twain who said
when your vocation becomes your vacation
that's when life becomes truly
magnificent and uh i'm privileged enough
to have that but i pursued it and one of
the secrets that i found and i know you
know this in your soul is that we all
know if you're going to be masterful at
something you don't show up you know as
the best in the world at something you
don't show up in environments that you
want to be in you get there because you
did things for thousands and thousands
of hours most of you know the concept of
mastery taking 10 000 hours that's an
arbitrary number but i'm sure you've
heard about you want to get really good
at something it's 10 000 hours because
when you do something enough with enough
intensity enough intention to constantly
get better when your labor is your love
and where your labor is something you
have to always get better at
then usually what happens is you get
these insights that allow you to serve
more but i also think that labor you
know we're talking about this weekend
what makes people fulfilled by their
labor is is their motives for it if your
motive is just to make money or just to
pay your bills or
or just to get rich or whatever you
think that's going to be those people
never really are fulfilled even if they
make the money um the most fulfilled
human beings in my experience and i've
had the privilege of working with
literally four million people from 125
countries now around the world the
people that are most alive regardless of
the economics are people that have found
something that they really feel the
motive is more than just themselves you
know we all know what it feels like when
you're trying to do so for something for
someone you love and you're not doing it
as a trade you're not trying to get
something back you're just doing it
because it's what you're made for and
i always tell people motive does matter
that if you're just doing something for
yourself there's nothing wrong with that
because
life supports whatever else supports
life if you're part of life and you're
trying to do something that's going to
make your life better i think the
universe god whatever proper term for
you whatever your belief system is
you know
infinite intelligence gets connected to
you and it gives you insights
but i think if you're trying to serve
more than yourself more life than just
you
when things support more of life more of
life shows up to support you and that
might sound kind of airy fairy but it's
my experience you know when you're
trying to support your family when
suddenly i had four kids three of them
overnight my life changed my intellect
changed my abilities changed because i
was trying to serve something more than
just me
uh when i started really focusing how to
serve a community and then a country and
then humanity as corny as it may sound
you get insights you won't get when
you're just trying to somehow you know
make your labor happen or get the job
done
so
labor could be love and it isn't for
most people most people i think are
unhappy in their life because they look
at
labor as work uh they look at as why
should i have to effort so much and in
my experience effort is the reward if
you are doing something you love it's
there so if you don't have it you might
say tony that's all wonderful you're in
fiji and you do what you love and i
don't have that thanks so much for
giving me the lecture
i'm not coming from that place
i'm coming from the place of saying you
can discover something that you're
really passionate about but in order to
do it you got to get out of the story of
what you can't do and you got to put
yourself on the line it's a purpose
larger than yourself that keeps you
going if it's only to meet your own
needs you will drop back into your
comfort zone but like you know for
example you know one of the great things
that came out of covid is i've spent
most of my life as a vagabond right
because i travel all over the earth so
in most
years i travel to you know 115 cities
and as you know most of my seminars are
multi-day seminars and i go to 12 to 16
countries you know like australia three
times
and so all of a sudden covet hits and i
had to adapt i found this way to adapt
and now i'm reaching ten times i mean my
largest seminar is now 900 000 people
versus 15 000. i was trying i did one
football stadium in 2019 with 38 000
people 40 000 people it was incredible
now that's a tiny seminar you know
because i couldn't put 900 000 people in
any stadium right so all this good comes
from that adaptation right figuring out
what to do but i think the other part of
it is you know during the same time when
the great gifts was i could find a way
to be home and still touch people's
lives so deeply and do it in a way that
was impactful i could see it and feel it
in their home i could see their children
i mean it's been amazing and now i do
both i do hybrid i got a thousand people
in front of me and 197 countries all
around me but one of the other benefits
was is we'd want to have a daughter and
i told my wife i'm not having a kid
after 50. i don't want to show up in
high school reunion and be 70 years old
but now i got an i've got a night i've
got a 48 year old daughter and a
nine-month-old daughter give you an idea
five kids of my granddads but my
daughter
like all the things i've ever done for
myself biohacking and health and all
that stuff like
now i'll be 80 at her high school
reunion so i i got to use these things
for a different reason and so that
doesn't let me get to a certain level
and stand there it's like man you know i
gotta be 92 to 102 range in order to do
that i got to know every tool in the
toolbox to turn around so gave me even
more drive and then what comes out of
that now is i can help anybody i mean
you know this is my new book by the way
it's called life force
it's coming out february the 8th but you
can pre-order it now on amazon or go to
tony robbins.com
but the point is
it's like i want to know every single
tool like i got totally obsessed even
more than i normally have because it's
like okay i got a higher purpose i got
all my grandkids all my children but now
i got my daughter right now you know out
of covid so many people have been shut
down terrible place and you know i'm
sure you've seen that um drug overdoses
are the largest they've ever been in
history as over 100 000 people last year
suicides one out of four kids under the
age of 30 according to the cdc whether
they're accurate i don't know have
considered suicide sometime in the last
two years because we all need a
compelling future we need to look
something look forward to so stanford
came to me
and their genetics lab has been doing
research on depression
and
what they found was that on by doing
meta studies is only 40 of the people
who go in for therapy who they get drugs
and therapy together usually only 40
make any improvement 60 don't improve at
all that's not a lot more than what you
get on some placebos
and so
they approached me and said a couple of
people went through one of your programs
one was clinically depressed they're not
anymore but we don't have any science on
this
would you be one of us do a science test
i said sure so they came out to the
state destiny seminar i do which helps
people to change their values and belief
structures i don't tell them what they
need to be they figure out what it needs
to be and it changes the way you
perceive life the way you experience
life how you feel what you do it's a
rewiring of your model of the world
basically in six days
and so they said we're going to model
this after the greatest breakthrough
they found in science and no one able to
follow up on they about two years ago
johns hopkins did a study on depression
and they gave people psilocybin right
which comes from magic mushrooms and
they did therapy for 30 days and at the
end of it 53 of the people were
depression free 30 days later never
happened like when we say 40 are helped
the average amount of help is 50 less
depressed right that's what the average
some people completely turn around some
people involved in this one 53 of the
people so it's four times the result of
any drug that ever been done but
unfortunately psilocybin's not legal so
they're still working on that and they
said we're gonna copy that exact study
and we're gonna have a group that they
compared to which is didn't go to the
seminar the comparison group is going to
do gratitude journaling and so forth
because positive psychology talks about
that and they said that's probably what
this seminar does it's just positive
thinking well the cool thing was when it
came out the results were so amazing at
stanford that they went and had two new
additional double blind people do the
research because it just seemed so
ridiculous
at the end of oh the first week 63 of
people had no
had no depression symptoms at the end of
six weeks it can increase through time a
hundred percent of the people had no
no depression symptoms nineteen percent
of the people had uh suicidal ideation
zero had suicidal ideation it blows away
any study it just came out it's coming
out next week in the psychiatric journal
which is the general american medic
association psychiat journal are the two
top journals in the field they can't
even believe it so they're going to do
more and they're
the actual scientific article says this
is more powerful than any drug therapy
or any forms of normal therapy combined
and what are we doing
we're getting people to change basically
those three questions to some extent
because your values control what you
focus on
if you're
security driven and you're here down in
my basement right now you're like
where's the exit right you came down the
slide like how do i get out of here
right if you're adventure driven you
don't care you don't even know where it
is so your focus is controlled by your
values and your belief systems right the
meaning of things is controlled by your
belief systems so those three decision
making things you know what i'm going to
focus on what doesn't mean what i'm
going to do shift and one good example
this j is maybe your audience can relate
to this
so we just took three patterns
so let's say focus most people have a
focus either on what they have or what's
missing we both we all do both
but what do you think most people focus
on more often what they have or what's
missing what's missing that's right
now
even achievers do that
like it's not like somebody's not
successful it's one of the reasons you
see these achievers that no matter what
they do it's never enough because think
about if you're always focusing what's
missing from your life how can you
sustain happiness
it's software that will not allow that
you'll feel happy for a little moment
you'll notice it's missing again
um what do you think's more often people
focus on what they can control or can't
control well they can't control yeah in
my seminars it's can control that's why
they go
i want to learn how to take control my
body or my finances or my business
whatever it is so if the opposite but
the average person it's what they can't
control and with kovid there's so much
you can't control around you that people
really sunk in that well how's someone
gonna feel just everyone think about it
if you're constantly focused on what's
missing from your life and what you
can't control
and then we'll add one more do you focus
more on the past
the present or the future we all do all
three but we tend to have one we focus
more on or do you think more people
focus
that's right
and achievers focus on the future
and happy people in the present
why is identity so important for us to
shape a positive powerful identity well
first of all so everybody understands
what i mean by identity is we all have a
way of identifying ourselves we have a
way of labeling ourselves
so
most of us came up with our labels based
on how we behaved
but really smart people can do stupid
things really nice people can be mean
mean people can be nice and so if you
judge yourself too soon and most
people's identity their labels for
themselves who they think they are has
been based on their past and often many
years ago and so they don't update it so
the the metaphor i'd give for identity
is like
it's your comfort zone it's not your
goals
so if you like if you took a temperature
in the room and said 68 degrees is my
comfort zone physically emotionally
financially i want more in my
relationship i want more physically
energy-wise i want more financially my
career but this is what i'm used to
and so what happens people stay in their
comfort zone for the most part and then
let's say something happens and you dip
you're a 68 degree or that's your
mentality and you drop down to 62 61 60
somewhere around 60 or 59
the heaters kick on and go whoa whoa
you're a 68 degree or what the hell are
you doing we've all experienced that all
of a sudden you go i'm not going to live
like this anymore i'm not going to be in
this relationship i'm not going to be
fat like this
boom and you get this drive and you
start to change but what most people
don't understand is it happens on the
upper end too
meaning let's say you got momentum you
start crushing it you start doing even
better than you think you go from 68 to
70 88 you're 98 degrees financially
emotionally spiritually whatever the
metaphor is and then what happens you're
going to say hey you're bringing us who
the hell do you think you are you're not
a 98 degree
right get back to 68 and if nothing else
the heaters stop you lose your drive and
that'll drift you back and not enough
the air conditioning kick on you start
to kind of sabotage yourself till you
get back to your comfort zone so unless
you expand your identity
change is temporary it's like when
someone says to me i've stopped smoking
it's been eight days
like a while
and i say why are you counting
so you can tell people how long you
lasted this time
like if i went to somebody and and i
said to you hey you know
louis you want a cigarette you're not
going to say what brand is it you know
no
i'm not a smoker notice how people i'm
not one of those that's not my identity
identity is the strongest force in the
human personality if you look lance
armstrong was a mixed identity now in
the culture
this is a guy that had to win and found
a way to win so when he was told he had
cancer
in his lungs in his brain and in his
testicles and he rides a bike
and he's gonna die
his answer was no i'm a champion i find
the way i will find the answer and he
did now unfortunately he bent the rules
around the sport and it kind of ruined
his reputation obviously but that
mentality his identity is why he
survived other people told they have
cancer and they're like it's over they
give up they start arranging their
affairs and so that psychological
difference is the number one thing i
work with people on because unless you
expand your identity you're going to
basically keep where you are you might
improve a little or not you might go up
and down a bit but you're going to stay
within a realm if you're going to have
an explosive breakthrough to another
level physically mentally financially
spiritually then we've got to not only
give you the tools
we got to shift that internal sense of
who you really are and have you find
that you are more than anything that's
ever happened to you that you can handle
whatever shows up even if it's
incredibly scary or uncomfortable when i
was growing up i grew up very poor and
i'm the oldest of three and i had to do
all the shopping all the grocery
shopping on my bicycle come home make
the meal and i was happy with all that
but then right when you wanted to be
done with your work and go watch sports
or do something great i had to wash the
dishes so i swore someday i will never
do the labor of washing dishes i will
afford a dishwasher i will find some way
to not have to do dishes i tell you
there's a background because when i told
him i couldn't be a furniture mover he
looks down and goes home only one other
job left
dishwashing
now dishwashing in india is a different
labor than you might picture in your
kitchen you're in this ashram and i
report and there's these milk solids and
yogurts on the floor and you're standing
in your bare feet and you're taking
these filthy dishes coming across and
it's four hours a day for six or seven
days i'm telling you i was so angry i
was so mad at myself that i was there as
a matter of was and i was washing these
dishes and upset and plus i was a vegan
and you know i didn't like the fact
there was milk on the floor i was
judgmental about everything in the
middle of all this stuff after about an
hour of being angry i got tired of being
angry and some part of me kicked in and
goes damn whatever you do you're the
best at it why don't you be the best
damn dishwasher so i started washing
these dishes with the frenzy and i'm
like come on guys speed this thing up
and something magical happened
the thing that i thought was most
disgusting and
filled with labor and work became play
and i started to laugh at myself and i
thought what an ego jerk you are to
think that you're below washing some
dishes and then i got beyond my ego and
jerk into why not just enjoy whatever
you do and then when you do
all of a sudden it's not work anymore
and that was my great spiritual
breakthrough i eventually did meet with
this guru and tried to straighten him
out but
he didn't think very much an 18 year old
kid straighten him out he laughed quite
a bit he did talk to my partners and
said i think you guys should just you
know keep teaching what you're teaching
and fit for life went on to be one of
the most successful books in history uh
but i can't claim credit for that as a
part of that little piece but i will
tell you that if you can
get over what if you can get yourself to
love to do the stuff you hate to do then
there's no limit to the success you can
have in your life
if you can take the things that you're
afraid you'd have to do to succeed in
your business or to succeed in your life
or
uh to succeed in your relationship there
are things everybody doesn't want to do
and the more focused you are and how
you're not going to do that the more
life seems to bring those things up for
you and makes them barriers my original
teacher was jim rohn when i met him when
i was 17
and i wanted to know why
all my fathers were broke because they
were good men
you know i loved all four of my fathers
and um
and i remember him saying tony we're all
equal as souls
but we're not equal in the marketplace
i was like what does that mean and he
said well think about it he goes you
need to become more valuable
if you want to have economic freedom he
said you have to work on yourself more
than anything else and you have to work
on it in a way where there's something
you can do for others better than anyone
else or at least more a better quality
and he gave me an example of like
working at mcdonald's and he said you
know if you work at mcdonald's
you know you make whatever it was in
those days five dollars an hour whatever
it was and he said you know i go yeah
but that seems so unfair and he goes
yeah and teachers i give example of
teachers and there's these billionaires
you know that make a billion dollars a
year hedge fund guy you know and he said
tony the guy you just mentioned he
provided a 40 return last year
and that went to nonprofits everything
else he said that means those
organizations double their money almost
every two years
he is adding massive value hundreds of
billion dollars so he made a billion he
goes this person is doing a job that
anyone can learn in 20 minutes or half a
day
so it's a beginning job he said you got
you got to think of it as one thing it's
all about adding value how can you do
more for others than anybody else in the
world and that
stuck with me i mean i was like i i
decided i wanted to do more further than
anybody in the world in order to do that
i had of certain skills and i went after
those skills and i still do like it's a
never-ending thing if you think you're a
master you're full of it right so i
think that's probably some of the best
advice i've received at least
on life and business and direction and
it affected my mission for most of my
life like help people achieve accomplish
everything achieve make it happen and if
you ask me i was fulfilled i'd say of
course i was and i was i loved it but
there's different levels of fulfillment
right if you've never smelled a rose and
someone's telling you what a rose is
like you think you know to experience it
yeah so i had this experience in india i
go about every two years and there's a
friend of mine there's built this
amazing facility and he had like a
quarter million people showing up for
his event they expected they would have
you know i think a hundred thousand
people and a quarter million people
showed up and then a million two by the
next morning
and the guy that was there is a really
smart guy and so i had a conversation
with his son
and he was thanking me for all this work
i've done he goes tony of all the things
you've taught me said i think maybe the
most important thing is all the ways i
can change my state i can get unstuck i
can i can get myself to follow through
he goes it is priceless
and he really thanked me and i said well
i really appreciate it and more
importantly i'm glad you're using it
right he goes but i just have one little
thing i'd like to ask you
because you know you talk about if
you're in a peak state you get peak
performance or if you're an energy rich
state a high energy state you're going
to produce differently than a low energy
state or a lousy state and i said yeah
he goes well what if you call those
high-energy states beautiful states
i said that's great because it's not
just happiness a beautiful state could
be excitement it could be gratitude it
could be love it could be kindness it
could be warmth i mean there's a million
beautiful states it's any high energy
state where no one has to tell you what
to do you'll do the right thing
so he goes okay i said sylvia beautiful
state's great and then he goes what if
we took all those lousy states those low
energy states those
those types of states and what we call
those suffering
and then when he said that probably kind
of like what you experienced it like nod
at me a little bit it's like suffering
i don't like suffering i don't suffer
but i do have times when i'm frustrated
or distressed or overwhelmed so i
couldn't deny it so i was like okay yeah
those would be suffering states i felt
this little trap going on in me and i
said why do you say this yes he goes
tony because i think it's the most
important distinction you've made but i
like to use some other words around it
he goes because i've set a spiritual
vision for myself
he said what's that
he said
my goal is to live in a beautiful state
every day no matter what he goes to me
that would be the most gorgeous life
because you know people have everything
and they're miserable they're pissed off
they're frustrated and so forth because
you deal with them all the time
i said that is brilliant i changed it
slightly for me i'd say
life is too short to suffer
for me that's where it starts life's too
short to suffer how could i possibly
suffer when i've been able to live this
magnificent life it's just the mind if
you don't direct this thing it directs
you it's like you use the mind or uses
you you use stress or stress uses you
yeah and so i said you know okay so how
am i going to do that because it's one
thing to say it yeah if you want to
develop the habits yeah right and when i
i found myself like getting on a plane
and you know i have my own plane now
obviously but
the time i used to go to australia four
times a year and i fly on qantas and
when i moved to florida it became 20
hours each way like a 40-hour trip for
one little visit yeah and i remember
getting on the plane and being so
stressed and i thought to myself
tony how could you be stressed you're
flying in a plane you can fall asleep
you can you know it's not my size bed
obviously but i'm first class and i'm
very lucky it's like come on what are
you what are you whining about in your
head and i realized what it was was that
they had no internet
so now i'm flying for 40 hours and
what's happening all my slacks all my
emails all my texts all it's all growing
fortunately i got this resolved in my
head before i got like lucky enough to
have my own plane and i remember when i
got worked out i got on a plane i flew
from here to l.a
i got on plane la and then you know the
captain comes on it goes uh this is
captain stubblebine it's gonna be a
beautiful flight to sydney and then he
said something i never heard before he
said today i have a special announcement
and it's this
we have for the first time in the
history of qantas international life
literally people stood up on the plane
and cheered and i want to stand up to
everybody to see me right so i stayed
there
so we all open up our ipads our our
phones are everything we got right we're
all typing doing our stuff on social
media
and nine minutes later what do you think
happened it breaks down it crashes let
me think it turns on
the thing that struck me out and it's
changed my life is i looked around me
and people were angry they were cursing
what the hell is wrong with this airline
they can't get this [ __ ] right
i looked around i was like
this is amazing nine minutes ago this
was a miracle now it's already an
expectation
and then i realized
all the unhappiness comes from all those
expectations you can't help have the
mind expect but you can direct it
and when you expect something that's not
met you get upset
yeah and it's like
what if if the only time i'm happy is
when everybody meets my expectations i
got 105 companies i got 3 800 employees
on four continents what are the chance
of someone screwing up right now meaning
doing something different than i think
they should 100
so it's like i need to make it so that
other people don't have to behave a
certain way for me to be happy the
secret to living is giving because
you're never going to be happy by what
you get
you'll get it you'll be excited for a
while for how long but
if you keep giving you'll become
something unique
that whether other people know it or not
you will know who you are people can
take away all your things they can't
take away who you become as a man or as
a woman as a soul
so business is a spiritual game how can
i do more for others than anybody else
how can i do it consistently i can do it
better how can i fall in love with my
clients and to over deliver levels they
can't even imagine
and develop this beautiful relationship
of such joy it isn't a transaction there
are transactions involved but you're not
doing it for the transaction you're
doing it to make that difference in
their business or their life
when you're driven by a mission more
than yourself you get a level of energy
that people just trying to take of
themselves will never have
so my heartfelt wish for you my dear
friends
is remember what business is it's a
spiritual game
it's about what can you give not what
can you get
you'll get plenty
if you'll give much more than you expect
to receive
if you do that you'll have more than
money
you have a life of incredible meaning
and your life will be blessed
dealing with the loss of someone you
care about is probably the most
difficult thing of all i would say maybe
uh as a child seeing
the level of frustration between my
parents you know i had four different
fathers
and watching them kind of um
you know accept whatever life gave them
as a it's why a lot of my drive came
about is seeing my father's be berated
by my mother who i love dearly um and
just watching them break down like you
know
probably the single most
painful event of my life but also shaped
me in such a beautiful way was when i
was 11 years old we had no money for
food and it was thanksgiving which in
america is a big holiday feast and so
we've been without food before we'd have
crackers and butter and you know we
survived but we weren't gonna have a
thanksgiving feast and there's knock out
the door and i go the door and there's
this giant guy there with groceries in
each hand and he had a pot beside him on
the ground with an uncooked turkey and
i i just like i said uh who are you here
for he goes i'd like to speak to your
father and my mom and dad were yelling
at each other saying things that you can
never take back and i'm trying to make
sure my younger brother and sister
they're five and seven years younger
wouldn't hear any of this
and
that day changed my life because i
thought it was gonna be the most
exciting day
dad dad go to the front what is it
that's it's for you you answered no it's
for you i remember open the door and i
was just so excited to see my father be
happy like we're gonna have a feast this
is gonna be incredible and he got angry
and he's like we don't accept charity he
went to slam the door in the man's face
and the man's foot was there so it
bounced off his foot
he still opened the groceries he's like
sir i'm just the delivery guy he said
it's it's not charity everybody has a
tough time someone bought this and
they're sending it to you as a gift my
father said we don't take charity he
goes to close the door again
this time the guy's shoulder was there
also so it bounced off again
and then i was standing right there and
there's this moment i'll never get where
this man looked at my father and he
looked at me and he said sir don't let
your ego make your family
uh
uh suffer
and the veins of my dad's face on the on
the side of his neck i'll never forget
the bulge i like his face turn around i
thought i was gonna punch him in the
face
and there's this moment my dad's
shoulders dropped
he took the groceries slammed the door
didn't say thank you
and stormed off and i almost remember
thinking
like how come he's not happy you know
you talk about pain it's like i love my
father so much
and
he
there's basically three decisions that i
think everybody makes in their life that
whether aware of it or not moment to
moment i figured this out afterwards
because i was so obsessed with what's
wrong because he eventually left our
family and that was the most painful
thing i ever have so it's like feeling
like i failed you know i blame myself
like why couldn't it get through to my
father when i was 11 years old
but later on it helped me understand
that three decisions are first you
decide what to focus on every moment of
your life there's something grabbing
your focus and you don't experience life
you experience the part of life you
focus on right what's wrong is always
available so is what's right right
and there are different kinds of focus
and my dad's focus that day was really
on what he hadn't done and i know that
because he kept muttering it and i
hadn't taken care of his family there's
no funny for thanksgiving somebody had
to give us charity
and then the second decision you make
about once you focus on something is
what does it mean
is this the end or the beginning if you
think it's the end of a relationship
you're going to behave different than
it's the beginning right um my dad's
meaning was that he was worthless
and so then the third decision is what
do i do which
whatever meaning you come up with
creates the emotions which affects what
you do and what he decided to do is
leave her family but for me it was like
this is amazing i mean you know we are
having thanksgivings you know this is a
this is incredible we got food what a
concept and then the meaning though is
what changed my whole life which was
wow
strangers care
that completely changed my life that
painful experience
i couldn't deny that somebody who wanted
no credit
delivered this food to my family and so
what i decided to do is say someday i'm
going to do this for another family so
when i was 17 i had two families and it
was
a euphoric experience i went and jeans
and a t-shirt i didn't go like the
delivery guy but i wanted to see the
face of the people and then the next
year was four people and then it was
eight and literally my thing was
doubling my little company and then i
got to a million people a year and i got
to four million people a year then i was
doing money master the game
i'm interviewing these billionaires jay
and i'm watching congress cut food
stamps it's now called the snap program
by i think it was six billion dollars so
every family that actually needs food
and my family was one of those back then
they all have to come up with a week's
worth of food out of every month so i
was like call my team and i said how
many people have i fed in my lifetime i
didn't know there was 42 million meals i
was like this is pretty cool and i was
like what if i said 50 million people
like my entire lifetime in one year and
there's like what if i did a hundred
million what if i fed a billion people
in 10 years so that was seven years ago
we're at 850 million meals right i'm
gonna hit the billion earlier than what
i promised and targeted and then i've
got a sustainable approach but i tell
you that because my worst day was my
best day
my the most painful day the day where i
felt i could do the least where i felt
infinite
led me to have new understandings new
skills new capacities new drives new
hunger i mean would i really be feeding
100 million people a year
100 million meals a year if i was well
fed as a child probably not and i'd love
to believe i'm such a perfect person but
no i'm just i just know what suffering
feels like so i don't want anybody else
to suffer you know so i think sometimes
the suffering experiences of our life if
we don't let them crush us
we let them drive us they they actually
become the best day in your life and
taking your worst day and making your
best day is a beautiful target for
anybody and if you want more fire and
espresso videos check out the one that
we recently did the link is right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there